[Musique]
pendant que les shadows que perdre leur
temps à pompe et n'importe quoi dans
l'espace
l'egypte se prépare à arriver sur la
terre car la terre approchait et
l'egypte y répéter la grande fête qu'ils
avaient organisée pour l'inaugurer
[Musique]
mais vu de loin la terre n'avait pas
l'air tellement tellement bien d'un peu
plus près ce n'était pas spécialement
mieux et de très près c'était encore
pire
pour ne rien vous cacher la terre en ce
temps là n'était pas si amusante que ça
du point de vue des sept en particulier
c'était pas du tout organisé et il n'y
avait personne pour s'en occuper
il restait bien quelques dinosaures en
retraite mais il disait que les 7 et
tout ça c'était plus de leur âge et que
de toute façon il était appelé à
disparaître
ce qu'ils firent en effet par la suite
comme chacun sait alors les gy be
décidèrent de remettre un peu d'ordre
dans tout ça et passer un premier coup
de peinture pour que ça fasse plus qu
ils en profitèrent pour repeindre aussi
des dinosaures qui le remercie beaucoup
de leur attention la terre comme ça été
quand même peu plus présentable et la
grande inauguration pouvait commencer
[Musique]